you're going to turn now to Republican
Congressman George Santos who was going
back to Capitol Hill back to Washington
after pleading not guilty to a 13-count
felony indictment in New York federal
charges include fraud money laundering
all of it connected to the campaign for
his seat on New York's Long Island and
Kate Lee Caitlin Huey Burns is with us
now after talking with Santos in quite
the scrum outside the courthouse
yesterday it was quite an event Good
morning Tony and good morning to
everyone well George Santos was released
on five hundred thousand dollars Bond
and he says he's heading back to
Washington but he'll be returning with
some diminished support last night house
Speaker Kevin McCarthy said he would not
back Santos's bid for re-election
New York Congressman George Santos left
a long island courtroom Wednesday vowing
to fight the federal charges against him
and taking a page from former president
Trump's legal Playbook I'm gonna fight
the Witch and I'm gonna take care of
Clary my name and I look forward to
doing that Santos pleaded not guilty to
financial charges including fraud money
laundering and lying on his disclosure
forms during his 2022 campaign what
evidence do you have that they don't
have that's extensive oh I I have plenty
of evidence that we will now be sharing
with the government in this case to make
sure that I can defend my industry
Federal prosecutors allege Santos
encouraged donors to make campaign
contributions through a company and use
the money to pay for personal expenses
including luxury designer clothing and
credit card payments Santos is also
accused of collecting thousands of
dollars in pandemic era unemployment
insurance while making 6 figures at a
florida-based investment firm Santos is
refusing to resign and even if indicted
under the Constitution he can't be
disqualified from being a member of
Congress or a candidate for re-election
are you planning on running for
re-election yes I am do you think
anybody believe you now well like I said
I will prove myself innocent and then
we'll move from there and re-election is
a very hard time away with a razor thin
majority in the house Speaker Kevin
McCarthy has resisted calling on Santos
to resign but Wednesday he went the
farthest to date to oppose Santos so you
don't plan to support Santa's
re-election that's what I said
and after leaving Court Santos mentioned
this indictment in a fundraising tweet
his next court appearance isn't until
the end of June but if convicted the
most serious charges carry a maximum
sentence of 20 years in prison were you
surprised that he used the term Witch
Hunt when he was talking we have seen
him evoke Donald Trump's Playbook with a
lot of this but these charges are very
serious this is not just fabricating
your resume lying about your past these
are fraud charges
to be continued Caitlyn good to have you
at the table thank you so much